in my eyes my baby girls are perfect  rapper Ti and his wife Tamika tiny  Harris are welcoming another perfect  little girl in April and only et is  taking you exclusively inside their  lavish baby shower the grand affair was  held Sunday in Atlanta and featured a  royal theme the couple posed for this  sweet shot together wear sparkly regal  accessories adorn the table the entire  family was in attendance at the bash  plus celebrity guests like Phaedra Parks  and kandi Burruss among others prior to  the event tiny gushed eet her pregnancy  has been quote great adding it will be  her last child and they haven't picked  out a name yet the only thing left to do  is get the 40-year old mama a push  present  tiny said she's been eyeing a new  Bentley truck well like her hubby song  goes  you get